[Applause]
after decade of spending cuts
prosecutions for rape at a record low
over 55 000 rates were recorded last
year just 1
109 rapists were convicted
behind these numbers unimaginable
suffering women paying an unthinkable
price for austerity
prime minister if someone was to come
and tell you that they'd been raped
would you as prime minister be able to
look them in the face
and say to them that there's a high
chance of justice being done
i want everybody to have that confidence
beth and at the moment i've got to tell
you that the answer to that is no i
don't think people do have enough
confidence in the criminal justice
system and that is certainly that's
led to this feeling of
of fury of frustration uh betrayal now
that feeling
is i think
caused by
uh frustration at the level of
successful prosecution your justice
secretary said that he was deeply
ashamed by the government's record are
you deeply ashamed i
certainly am not
happy with the way the things have been
going you said the cps are not dealing
with complaints fast enough or taking
them seriously enough but if we look at
the cts it's not just the ccps spending
it foul cuts 28 percent
in real time no no let me finish between
2010 to 2019.
so the cuts make it more difficult to
prosecute and you can
you have to acknowledge don't you that
actually this is partly on
conservative governments
we put another 200 prosecutors back in
it what did what it is
i think the the cps
government cuts could be driving down
rape prosecutions after the criminal
justice system and this is a quote from
them was close to breaking point
because of cuts i know you're changing
we are things many more prosecutors in
and have done but did you acknowledge
that that was part of the issue the
issue is i don't think it's always and
everywhere a question of more public the
cps and the justice department have
faced carts and it's not just about the
cps and the police it's also on the
government i certainly acknowledge
my over my responsibility for all of
this but what we're doing is putting
more uh more prosecutors into the cps
what i've said to the prosecution broker
the lowest on records and i'm totally
fed up with this you have set a target
for your government to increase back to
2016 levels that's
5190 prosecutions
that's
2991 convictions by 2024 will you make
that as prime minister your personal
responsibility if we come back here in
two years time i care deeply about this
this is will you will you make that your
puzzle you've made a department for
leveling up so can you
to deliver that it's going to be
incredibly tough partly because of the
evidential problems so you're not sure
you can hit the title we will do
everything that we can
throwing everything out to answer your
you need to get back to your first
question do i want people to feel
confident in the streets yes i do beth
and by the way i do think people should
would you like to just apologize to
women over this in the way that robert
buckley i think that the i think that
certainly
on behalf of
government overall i think that this is
something where we where we have a
government the whole system has not done
well
a prime minister acknowledging the
problem and promising progress empty
words unless more women and girls get
justice beth rigby sky news manchester